-Performing "Escapism"
and "Worth It"
from her debut album,
"My 21st Century Blues,"
please welcome Raye!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Just a heartbroke sis,
high heels, 6-inch ♪
♪ In the back of the nightclub,
sippin' champagne ♪
♪ I don't trust any of
these...I'm with ♪
♪ In the back of the taxi,
sniffin' some pain ♪
♪ Drunk calls, drunk texts,
drunk tears, drunk...♪
♪ I was lookin' for a man
who was on the same page ♪
♪ Now it's back to the intro,
to the bar ♪
♪ To the Bentley, to the hotel,
to my old ways ♪
♪ 'Cause I don't wanna feel
how I did last night ♪
♪ I don't wanna feel how
I did last night ♪
-♪ Doctor ♪
-♪ Anything, please ♪
-♪ Doctor, doctor ♪
-♪ Have mercy on me ♪
♪ Take this pain away ♪
-♪ I don't wanna feel ♪
-♪ Mm ♪
♪♪
♪ Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun ♪
♪ If my body was a boat,
could you steer that, sailor? ♪
♪ Make it feel like it's
a 1960s Hollywood trailer ♪
-♪ Old school, I like ♪
-♪ Classic like cars,
classic like Elizabeth Taylor ♪
-♪ Taylor, Taylor ♪
-♪ I need you to romance me,
yeah, I need a giver,
not a taker ♪
-♪ Ooh, it's what I need ♪
-♪ But, baby boy, no, I ♪
♪ Could love you ♪
♪ If I really wanted to ♪
♪ You could be,
be my glass of wine ♪
♪ When the sun sets,
help me exhale all the ♪
♪ Baby, bae, b-b-bae,
b-b-baby, would you ♪
♪ Would you make it alright? ♪
♪ Mm, maybe that much better? ♪
♪ If you wanted,
you could make it all worth it ♪
-♪ Worth it ♪
♪ Ooh, when I see
the sun rising ♪
♪ You make it that much better ♪
♪ So I hope you're gonna make it
all worth it ♪
-♪ Worth it ♪
-♪ Doo, doo, doo, doo, doo ♪
♪ Worth all of the time
I'm 'bout to give you, baby ♪
♪ So I hope you're gonna
make it all ♪
-♪ Worth it, worth it ♪
-♪ Doo, doo, doo, doo, doo ♪
♪ Give all of the time
I should be be working on me ♪
♪ So I hope you're gonna make it
all worth it ♪
-♪ Worth it ♪
-♪ This is the night ♪
-♪ Something 'bout
it's making me cry ♪
-♪ My soul, it did decide ♪
-♪ Feel my body shiver ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
♪ And I need you to let me
have the time of my life ♪
♪ Checked your credentials,
South residentials ♪
♪ Ooh, baby boy,
you got so much potential ♪
-♪ I could ♪
-♪ Mm, I could love you, yes ♪
♪ If I really wanted to ♪
-♪ You could be,
be my glass of wine ♪
-♪ When the sun sets,
help me exhale all the ♪
♪ Baby, bae, b-b-bae,
b-b-baby, would you ♪
♪ Would you make it alright? ♪
♪ Or maybe that much better? ♪
♪ If you wanted,
you could make it all worth it ♪
-♪ Worth it ♪
-♪ Worth it, worth it, hey ♪
♪ When I see the sun rising ♪
♪ You make it that much better ♪
♪ So I hope you're gonna
make it all ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Worth all of the time
I'm 'bout to give you, baby ♪
♪ So I hope you're gonna
make it all worth it ♪
-♪ Worth it ♪
-♪ Doo, doo, doo, doo, doo ♪
♪ Give all of the time
I should be be working on me ♪
♪ So I hope you're gonna
make it all ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
♪ Worth it ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.